♪ ♪
>> Laura: HERE IS HILLARY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
APPARENTLY RECENTLY ON PBS AND
IN RESPONSE TO A QUESTION ABOUT
TRUMP'S URGING HER TO RUN AGAIN,
MRS. CLINTON SAID THIS.
>> MAY BE THERE DOES NEED TO BE
A REMATCH.
OBVIOUSLY COME I CAN BEAT HIM
AGAIN.
>> Laura: NOTE TWITTER,
CLINTON CLAIMED SHE WAS JOKING.
BUT REMEMBER, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE CLINTONS, SO THE TRUTH
IS ALWAYS A BIT ELUSIVE.
WELL, WHAT ARE THE CHANCES THAT
HILLARY JUMPS ON THE 2020 RACE?
IT AIN'T 0% BUT DOES SHE THINK
ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME?
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT IS WHAT ONE OF HILLARY'S
CLOSEST CONFIDANTES TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO, I
DISMISSED THE IDEA OF HILLARY
2.0 OUT OF HAND.
SHE WOULDN'T BE THAT ARROGANT
AND GRACIOUS TOWARDS THE CURRENT
FIELD, NO WAY.
BUT THEN THE WEAKEST OF THE
DEMOCRAT SLATE EVEN SURPRISED
ME.
NOTHING IS WORKING.
THE WALKING, TALKING
MATHEMATICAL MACHINE KNOWN AS
JOE BIDEN MAY HAVE DROPPED IN
THE POLLS FOR A FEW WEEKS, BUT
NOW, HE'S BACK ON TOP.
AND WHAT SEEMS TO BE THE
GRUDGING RECOGNITION THAT THE
OTHER TOP CANDIDATES, WARREN AND
SANDERS ARE JUST NOT GOING TO
CUT IT IN KEY BATTLEGROUND
STATES WHERE COMMON SENSE STILL
MEAN SOMETHING.
NOW MRS. CLINTON MAY FEEL
VINDICATED BY THE INTERESTINGLY
TIME RELEASE OF AN INTERNAL
STATE DEPARTMENT REPORT THAT
SOMEHOW MANAGED TO EXONERATE HER
IN THE MATTER OF EMAIL DELETIONS
AND HANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
ALTHOUGH HILLARY STAFF SAID THEY
WERE FAULTED TO COME OF THE
REVIEW CERTAINLY GIVES
MRS. CLINTON COVER.
PLUS, I MEAN WHO DOESN'T THINK
THAT HILLARY IS A STRONGER
CANDIDATE THAN THAT GOOFBALL,
BIDEN.
TO USE ONE OF HIS FAVORITE
PHRASES, COME ON, MAN.
I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
COME ON, IS IT TOO LATE?
IT'S TOO LATE FOR HILLARY.
IT'S TOO LATE TO GET INTO THIS
ALREADY CROWDED FIELD?
MY ANSWER IS, IT IS REALLY UP TO
THE PARTY.
IF THE VOTERS AREN'T JABBED BY
THE LIKELY FRONT RUNNERS, IT
WOULD BE STUPID TO NOT SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER ANOTHER CLINTON BED.
SHE HAS INSTANT NAME RECOGNITION
FROM A MASSIVE FUND-RAISING --
FUND-RAISER APPARATUS THAT COULD
BE REACTIVATED AND ROLLED
CAMPAIGN TEAM WOULD QUICKLY
RECONSTITUTE AND OTHER CAMPAIGNS
RECONSTITUTE AND OTHER CAMPAIGNT
RECONSTITUTE AND OTHER CAMPAIGNE
RECONSTITUTE AND OTHER CAMPAIGNM
RECONSTITUTE AND OTHER CAMPAIGNN
RECONSTITUTE AND OTHER CAMPAIGNT
SHE STEPPED BACK IN.
AND LET'S FACE IT, SHE HAS BEEN
TO THE TRUMP RODEO BEFORE SO SHE
KNOWS THE SHOW BETTER THAN
ANYONE.
HAS ANOTHER HILLARY TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST," HER VIEW
IS, I AGAINST THE SKY.
I KNOW HOW TO DO THIS.
ANOTHER REASON SHE IS INCHING
TOWARDS A RERUN, DIPPING AND THE
POLITICAL CONVERSATION
UNINVITED.
>> MOST RECENTLY IT WAS HER
GRATUITOUS SWIPE AT
TULSI GABBARD.
WHILE BERNIE SANDERS GENTLY
APPROACHED HILLARY FOR THE
SMEAR, ELIZABETH WARREN JUST
NERVOUS ABOUT THE LOOMING
CLINTON SHADOW.
>> BACK INTO THE NEWS RECENTLY.
I JUST WANT TO START THERE.
>> DO YOU THINK SHE IS HELPING
OR HURTING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
I HAVE NO COMMENT FOR THAT.
>> Laura: GOAL, SHAKING.
OF COURSE, THE OTHER ANIMATING
FORCE FOR HILLARY MAY BE THE
DEMOCRAT VIEW LB AT ERRONEOUS
THAT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS
GRAVELY WOUNDED -- WOUNDED BY
THE LIKELIHOOD OF IMPEACHMENT.
I CAN IMAGINE THIS AND MAYBE YOU
CAN AS WELL, THESE WILL PAID,
OVERPAID POLITICAL CONSULTANTS
MAKING THIS PITCH, IT GOES
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
MADAM SECRETARY, EVEN IF THE
ECONOMY REMAINS STRONG, OUR
INTERNAL POLLING IS SHOWING THAT
VOTERS WILL ABANDON TRUMP AND
CHOOSE YOU.
ANOTHER POLITICAL NAME BRAND TO
STOP THE CHAOS COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON.
AND JUST THINK, YOU WILL FINALLY
BE ABLE TO MAKE HISTORY AT THE
FIRST FEMALE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
DON'T LET THE DREAM DIE.
AMERICA IS CALLING YOU, HISTORY
IS CALLING YOU.
SAVE US FROM TRUMP, DO IT FOR
THE GRANDKIDS.
AND THAT IS FOR MRS. CLINTON'S
RECENT BRAVADO AND TRASH TALKING
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP --
>> HE KNOWS HE'S AN ILLEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT.
HE IS EITHER LYING OR DELUSIONAL
OR BOTH.
IT IS LIKE HITTING 66 MILLION
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION AND
LOSING TO A CORRUPT HUMAN
TORNADO.
>> Laura: BIG DEAL.
THAT IS JUST TALK UNLESS THAT
IS, SHE WANTS TO BACK IT UP WITH
ACTION.
GET BACK IN, HILLARY, THE WATER
IS WARM.
THE OTHER THREAD OF THIS
NARRATIVE THAT MUST NOT BE
OVERLOOKED IS THAT THE INSTANT
THE HEARTY SUPPORT SHE WOULD
RECEIVE IMMEDIATELY FROM THE OLD
AND BATTLE DEEP STATE AND
PROFESSIONAL AND DIPLOMATIC
CORPS WHO ARE NOW BATTLING
TRUMP.
YOU DON'T THINK THIS GROUP WOULD
RATHER GO BACK TO THE GOOD OLD
DAYS OF CLINTON AGAIN?
AND KISS THIS ENTIRE AMERICA ERA
GOODBYE?
SO THERE YOU HAVE IT FROM A
COMBINATION OF HILLARY'S PRIDE,
HER DESIRE FOR REVENGE, A WEAK
DEMOCRATIC FIELD AND A
CONSULTANCY CLASSIC BAND AND
THE DESERT MAY BE POINTING US
TOWARDS ANOTHER TRUMP/CLINTON
FACE-OFF.
OF COURSE, HILLARY IS SMART
ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT THE ONLY
THING WORSE THAN LOSING ONES TO
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE LOSING
TWICE TO HIM.
AND THAT TOO IS A DISTINCT
POSSIBILITY.
>> ARE YOU SUGGESTING SOMEONE IS
TRYING TO MAKE A REAL LIFE
SEQUEL?
WHO WOULD DO THAT, A SEQUEL?
MANY SEQUELS HAVE A PRAYER
SURPASSED THEIR ORIGINAL.